bonsoir dans la caste merci d'être avec
nous on se rend compte que même si
l'état islamique a marqué le pas
évidemment a même été décimé la
situation reste extrêmement instable en
série oui tout à fait malheureusement la
situation est resté instable c'est le
statu quo qui ont syrie il n'y a pas
même pas le début d'un processus
politique ce qui est malheureux l'onu
qui n'arrivent pas à aboutir à un début
de processus politique des acteurs aussi
qu'ils sont qui joue un rôle principal
on syrie je peux dire et malheureusement
c'est avec le govic ovide 19
on est on est on est en mode on va dire
mode de mode aux arrêts c'est à dire il
n'y a pas de décision
le dossier est maintenant entre les
mains de nidau ministère des affaires
étrangères russe a rien qui bouge
il est certain que le président assad
il est il y a il y là où il est toujours
actuellement président de la syrie mais
il règne sur un pays en ruine une crise
économique qui frappe naciri la loi
césar qui va continuer il n'y aura pas
de retour de toute façon le retour de la
syrie dans la ligue arabe
la crise va continuer il y aura plus de
pauvreté
tant qu'il n'y a pas un début de
processus politique
je suis pas en train de blâmer les
autres pays moi je crois qu'il ya une
erreur qui a été commise par tout le
monde par les pays payer a nui aux pays
qui sont pas amis où qu'ils ont plutôt
qu'ils ont choisi qu'ils avaient une
mauvaise décision à l'époque quand ils
ont pris la coalition et le conseiller
national suivie par la coalition
suivi par le comité de négociation
syrien comme le seul interlocuteur
surtout dans un pays qui comme la syrie
qui a une diversité ethnique et
religieuse on peut pas avoir un seul
intérêt d'un interlocuteur
alors oui en ce moment il ne faut rien
espérer
assad va être entre guillemets quand on
parle des élections c'est pas des vraies
élections
on sait très bien il va être il va
continuer à régner sur un pays en
faillite et et mais ce que j'attends
j'attends la femme de kobe pour
commencer une nouvelle initiative avec
d'autres syriens alors justement
emmanuel macron lui a de nouveau plaidé
pour une solution politique c'est ce que
vous mais nous dira en substance la
seule possible selon le président
français
c'est un bon diagnostic que pose
emmanuel macron entre jusqu'ici la
france a quand même été impuissante sur
le terrain avec ses alliés oui
certainement toute façon l'europe est
impuissante face en europe n'a pas joué
ils n'ont pas une armée ils ont soutenu
à l'époque de président aux landais ont
soutenu quelques brigades armées une
certain malheureusement c'étaient des
islamistes ils ont ils ont détruit aussi
des armes à quelques brigade ou ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque l'armée l'armée
libre l'armée syrienne libre qui après
c'est tombé bien sûr c'est ça mon les
autres on les a trouvés entre c'était
entre les mains des islamistes
alors il y avait il y avait toute façon
une mauvaise décision
des erreurs qui ont été commises par
beaucoup de pays et pour cette raison je
crois que le président macron a hérité
de cette politique erronée et comme je
les dis on est toutes façons c'est la
crise aujourd'hui de kovy ce n'est pas
la série n'est plus n'est pas une
priorité pour nos coûts beaucoup de pays
alors jean yves le drian lui a pointé la
responsabilité de la russie et de l'iran
soutient on le rappelle dans du
président bachar el-assad dans ce
conflit c'est aussi la russie qui a
oeuvré pour chasser les islamistes
oui il est vrai aussi que la russie bien
sûr moi j'étais pour l'intervention
russe en 2000 a enfin 2015 en séries
c'est pour chasser des islams et si vous
vous rappelez il y avait quand même les
brigades qui ont pris le contrôle de
certains pays de certaines villes et
alzonne et régions et provinces en syrie
n'est malheureusement c'est à dire après
je peux dire après le 2018 j'ai le
pressentiment malheureusement pour je le
dis je le considère et je considère
toujours la russie comme un pays ami
ils sont ils sont ils sont quand même il
n'y a pas une vraie décision c'est comme
si c'était c'est inouï et argile n'y a
pas une vraie stratégie par rapport à la
série qu'est ce qu'on va faire à part
parce que il y aura pas de
reconstruction série soyons réalistes
surtout avec à lui à césar il n'y aura
pas de reconstruction il n'y aura pas le
retour des réfugiés
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire après magie
pas en train de demander au régime
un régime qui est capable que pour moi
c'est un héros c'est en fait même le
président syrien qui est déconnecté de
la réalité
je suis en train de demander aux devoirs
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec certains
pays surtout avec la russie qui est
quand même qui a démontré une vraie
amitié et une vraie volonté de trouver
solution mais depuis 2018 et n'y a rien
de tout en tout cas bachar al assad se
présente lui pour un quatrième mandat
est ce qu'il est toujours l'homme de la
situation
non je crois pas je crois que nous avons
tous échoué opposition opposants pensent
bien sûr opposition et régime y compris
bien sûr charles la salle n ya pas un
mois la syrie c'est qui a perdu le
peuple syrien a perdu tout le monde a
perdu parce que régnait sur sur sur un
pays semi pays où un client ruine c'est
pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on
appelle la présidence ou président est
un pays alors il faut faire je suis
aussi réaliste
je cherche des moyens je cherche aussi
d'avoir des solutions réalistes c'est à
dire je crois toujours un changement
graduel
je crois aussi peut-être lui il sera
réélu ça c'est sûr mais et ne peut pas
rester surtout la russie ne pourrait pas
tolérer une situation en syrie pendant
beaucoup de temps et beaucoup d'années
puisque les sanctions resteront toute
façon sur ce pays
tous ceux qui qui essaie d'aider le
régime ou d'investir en syrie seront
sous sanction il faut trouver une vraie
solution la vraie solution je crois que
peut-être ça pourrait advenir de la part
de ce régime c'est à dire les russes
peut-être je sais que c'est très
compliqué surtout avec la présence des
de l'iran dans la région et surtout en
syrie
ce n'est pas si facile surtout nous
savons très bien l'hostilité de deux des
rangs pour avoir un changement même un
changement graduel eux qui adore
toujours les élections organisées et de
savoir quel candidat doit être présenté
pour des élections
alors voilà tout est compliqué il est
certain mais peut-être ne pourrons
ensemble trouver un solution graduelle
peut-être le régime pourrait aussi
ouvrir le pays
laisser les partis ils sont à l'étranger
les partis politiques de d'avoir ou
d'être en place en syrie et d'avoir des
représentants pour en syrie il faut il
faut quand même animer la vie politique
en syrie commencé à animer une vie
politique en syrie
on peut commencer par aussi par des
élections du parlement après plus tard
pour avoir des vrais représentants de
l'opposition et de certains
certains partis ils se trouvent à
l'étranger 2 d'avoir des représentants
qui peuvent être dans le parlement et
c'est à partir de là on peut nous
pourrons parler d'un changement ou d'un
changement graduel mais dans d un début
d'un processus sans merci
et on va cassis d'avoir été avec nous